first of all thank you for putting me on
the cover of Rolling Stone I always want
to say that to you whenever I get the
chance because I was very grateful
because being a disc jockey you're on in
one market and so for you to have
selected me for a cover was quite an
honor but I'll never forget I had this
idea that I would pose for the cover of
Rolling Stone with just my head and the
thorny crown you know the crown of Jesus
and I submitted it to Rolling Stone and
it was rejected it had to be rejected
because you said hey I don't know if it
was you but we can't put that on the was
it you yeah I thought it was a great
cover I I thought it would have been
dramatic as hell but you said hey if we
put you on the newsstand with this you
[ __ ] because no one will no one will
put this on the newsstand it was a great
cover it was a great image I mean you
looked very jesus-like in that you know
and look like a like a literal you know
crossword Jesus the crown of thorns I
mean and the curly hair and Jesus was a
Jew right yeah and um but at that time
and and I forget what the Sensibility it
would have created such a [ __ ] storm I
mean Howard Stern's mocking Jesus you
know right and you were right and if you
go up against religious groups
it's tough because they get such a pass
for so much hypocrisy the reason I did
it was was so many Church groups were
raising money off of trying to get me
off the air I thought well here let me
put the thumb in the eye but it was your
magazine and I realized that you know
you couldn't it was too much of a risk
it was too much of a sort of cost us
millions of dollars and people running
from it years later Kanye West did it
and it was acceptable to put him on the
the cover of Rolling Stone with that I
think there was about 10 years between
those two times and I think the times
had changed over those 10 years it was
less brisky was seen like less of it you
know it's a decline of religion listen
thank you for all the years that you
chronicled rock and roll because for me
there was no better magazine than
Rolling Stone and being on the cover was
an honor beyond my wildest dreams still
one of my greatest honors and one of the
greatest moments of my career